hi morning everyone how are you
good fantastic it's great to see you all
great to be here in Darlington with
Peter at this leading health and Life
Sciences Center and actually wonderful
to be joined by so many of our amazing
student nurses and paramedics and actual
researchers as well who had the pleasure
to spend a bit of time with now earlier
this year I set out my priorities for
the country which are there behind me
and that's the half inflation to grow
the economy to reduce debt cut waiting
lists and stop the boats and this
morning I was at North tees hospital
with a man who runs the NHS and and
other colleagues to launch our plan to
cut waiting times in Urgent and
Emergency Care something that we've been
working on for a little bit now I don't
need to tell all of you about some of
the challenges that we're all
experiencing in our emergency
departments at the moment now there's a
lot of reasons for that if we're still
recovering from the impact of covid
we've had I think the worst flu season a
matter of correct me in about a decade
so it's been been pretty tough for
everyone and we've still got far too
many people in hospitals who we would
much prefer and they would prefer to be
back home in their communities being
looked after but look we're not alone in
facing these challenges you can see
similar things in Wales in Scotland even
internationally in Canada or in Italy
and Germany that all people grappling
with similar challenges but we still
need to do something about it and that's
why last year when the chancellor stood
up and announced What's called the
Autumn statement we had to make some
difficult decisions I think you all
remember what happened and we had to do
some things to get our debt and
borrowing under control in spite of all
of that we prioritize the NHS and social
care with billions of pounds of extra
funding because I know it's your
priority it's my priority and the
government's priority too but the
question is and what you want to ask me
is well how are you going to spend that
money so it actually makes a difference
because we need to improve this and
today's plan does that I believe there's
five very specific things we're doing
first is more capacity that means 5000
more beds 800 more ambulances 100 more
mental health ambulances just to put
more capacity into the system the second
thing is to increase the workforce
making sure that we've got more doctors
more nurses more types of all
professional actually and many of you
that I've met this morning are going to
be here and help us deliver on that and
we want to support you to work as
flexibly as possible when you get there
the third thing was discharge I
mentioned we've got 14 000 people in
hospitals at the moment who ought to be
either back home or in their communities
and that's causing some of the
challenges that we're seeing in our
hospitals at the moment so we've got a
plan to speed discharge with particular
money and some initiatives to help there
the fourth thing is having more people
cared outside of hospital I think most
people don't need to be in hospital they
don't want to be in hospital and there
are some great examples where we can
treat people with respiratory conditions
in Virtual Wards or indeed new Frailty
and four Services again keeping people
out of hospital so we're going to do far
more of those and lastly we're going to
improve 111 and we're going to put
different types of people into the 111
service so people can get the help that
they need on the phone and hopefully end
up not needing to go to a e in the first
place so those are the five points of
the plan and all of that is going to
have an enormous amount of support to
help those trusts that need extra help
now I was with Kath and her team this
morning at North tees North tees is an
example of somewhere that is doing
brilliantly thanks to the incredible
joined up working between all the
different people at Northeast they've
really figured out how to attack this
problem and make an enormous difference
to so many people's lives and what we
need to make sure is that we spread that
kind of best practice out and about
across the country and that's what
Amanda and I in the health secretary
were were talking to the team at North
teas about this morning so that in a
nutshell is the plan with more more beds
more ambulances more staff better social
care and if we can deliver on it if we
can deliver on it then I think we will
see in fact I know we will see the
largest and fastest ever Improvement in
emergency waiting times in the nhs's
history that is the ambition of our plan
that we've set out today and partly
because of all the time I've spent with
brilliant people like Kath and her team
this morning all of you who are training
I feel really confident that we can
deliver it because ultimately it's
because of all of you and the hard work
and the Ingenuity that you bring to your
jobs day in day out that we're going to
fix this problem we're going to improve
things for patients and make an enormous
difference to people up and down the
country so thank you for your help in
making that a reality thank you for
being here today and with that I'd be
delighted to answer any and all of your
questions on all things NHS or anything
else or tea side or anything else at all
that you want I'll say right who wants
to go first yes
hi I'm a student nurse at teesside
University and I'm based at Northeast
hospital and as a student it can be
quite difficult I'm a mature student the
reality is I have to work alongside my
studies which is fine but when we're on
placement it gets quite difficult
and I know as a student I'm very
grateful for the NHS bursary that you
you know introduced the five thousand
pounds really grateful but while we're
on placement it gets really difficult
do you ever or envisage any change to
the funding for student like nurses and
Allied Health Professions that might
just help us when we're on placement
because if we're doing you know 37 and a
half hours
you know when we're on placement it's
really hard to work alongside that and
the bursary is brilliant but do you
think there might ever be a change to
funding or just a little bit extra money
for students you know just to keep
retention you know there are people in
my cohort that have dropped out just
financially it can be difficult so yes
yeah Lynn thank you and it was great to
see you guys
um earlier on and thanks for what what
you're doing and you're absolutely right
it was we recognize the challenges that
were there for many of you who are
trying to juggle what you've juggled
being on your course and making
everything work alongside and that's why
we reintroduced that bursary
um which as you said and thank you for
acknowledging that because that's five
thousand pounds a year of nurse's
bursary it was something that the RCN
you know your union was really Keen for
us to do a couple of years ago and we
prioritized it and you know before we'll
get onto other things to do with pay as
well later on but that that's something
that does it costs a lot of money but I
thought was the right thing to do
um to help now alongside that you ask
about other things there are also
maintenance grants that are available
from memory and but we're always looking
to make sure that the support we've got
in place helps and you know with the
extra funding that we're putting in to
the NHS shortly we're going to publish a
Workforce plan
right which is something that many of
you and your colleagues have asked for
ages we are going to finally do that and
as we publish that Workforce plan and we
kind of know okay great we need this
many nurses this many doctors this many
paramedics Etc figuring out do we have
all the bits in place to make sure we
end up with that that number of people
is going to be really important so we
will look as we do that at making sure
that the support is in place to get all
the Fantastic nurses we need the other
thing is um is training once you qualify
as one of the other things that we did
which again was I've seen many of you
nodding because a lot of what you you
know you all said to us was that's great
we do our course here then we go and
work we'd like some support with
continuous development and and we've now
put in place a CPD budget for every all
of you when you graduate and start work
you get access to I think it's about a
thousand pounds from memory again a CPD
budget so that you can continue learning
more doing more and that's actually how
we're going to solve some of these
problems because if you think of what
all of you can do now compared to what
nurses could do 20 years ago it's
changed dramatically and if we can do
more of that it will help us have a more
effective NHS and make sure you have you
have really fulfilling careers as well
perfect right who's uh who's next yes
sir
I am a local community pharmacist and I
I would like to know are you aware prime
minister that the perilous Financial
State the Community Pharmacy services in
at the moment in England and Wales there
are a lot of community pharmacies who
are really struggling from a 30 cut in
real terms funding over the last seven
years and now we're at the brink of
closure and it'll not be long before you
see some pharmacies closing can you
please urgently inject some funding into
the Community Pharmacy service
and the second question
would be how have you considered a
national Pharmacy First scheme to ease
pressure on the NHS for the in a e and
GP surgeries where patients could come
to a pharmacy first and be triaged in
that way a well-funded service would do
a lot to help the NHS yes so look I I'm
I'm biased on this because
um as some of you may know and Amanda
laughing so my mum was a community
pharmacist she owned her own Pharmacy I
grew up working in it most of my
childhood so I'm a big fan of pharmacies
my dad was also a GP so I saw both sides
of it and I think your two questions
actually go really well together so how
do we make sure that local pharmacies
are sustainable into the future it's
figuring out what more can Community
pharmacies do and in the same way I was
talking about nurses if I think about
all the things that a pharmacy does
today compared to when I worked in my
mom's Pharmacy that has evolved and
changed and to your point I think
there's more we can do and it was one of
the things that Amanda and I and the
team have been discussing is seeing how
more we can move towards a pharmacy
first model we saw that during covid
with vaccinations and bit by bit there
are more services that can be put into
pharmacies or pharmacists by about 20 25
or six are going to have the ability to
prescribe and I think that's the area
that many pharmacists have said to us
say hang on whether it's for UTIs or
other things or minor ailments would it
be possible for pharmacies to do more
and that's something we're actively
looking at looking at what does that
mean for regulation for we have to get
our antibiotic safety right because if
our chief medical officers were here
they would say you know actually we do a
very good job of this country of not
making sure that people develop an
immunity to antibiotics and they want to
make sure that that remains the case so
that's what they would say if they were
here but also things like blood pressure
checks is another thing where we
probably can do more in pharmacies and
if we can get that right there's so much
undiagnosed high blood pressure which
then leads all the paramedics here which
then leads to people needing ambulance
call out if we have pharmacies doing
more blood pressure checks for example
you know getting people the treatment
they need earlier stopping the ambulance
call out so there's a lot of
opportunities there and that's all the
things that we are in the process of
looking out in the same way that today
we published a pretty comprehensive plan
on tackling
urgent and emergency care we're going to
do something very similar for Primary
Care as well so last year we published a
plan on electives which is in process
and working so we're getting the backlog
down on elective surgery today the focus
is on emergency care and then the next
step will be on primary care so you can
expect here us talk a little bit more
about pharmacies pharmacies then but I
always have to be careful I said I'm
biased so I have to check my my natural
Pro Pharmacy bias in those things right
who's uh who's got another question yes
Miss
hi I'm Amani I'm a learning disability
nurse by background I'm also a lecturer
here at T side
um so there are approximately 1.5
million people with learning
disabilities in the whole of the UK and
only 17 000 diverse nurses in the whole
of the UK
um so just wondering what ideas you have
for funding for learning disability
services or learning disability nurse
education
well thank you for what you do it's um
it's incredibly important actually I see
in my own constituency actually
relatively recently I was talking to
someone who does the same thing that
that you do in it and it makes such a
difference to people so thank you for
that and thank you also for helping
train the next generation of us is going
to come through so one of the things
we're actually in the process of
publishing is apply we're going to have
a new uh we're going to have a new piece
of legislation that changes all the
guidance about how we treat people with
learning disabilities and indeed autism
it's one of the things that I think
we've learned more about over the years
and the way our current guidance and
regulation is set up is is probably not
as
as it should be and lots of your
colleagues are helping us get that right
to make sure that the treatment is in
place for people at the right stage will
identify things early enough and then
put the support around around people
that they need because if you look at
the prevalence of it it's gone up
considerably particularly at young age
and I think I think all of us want to
make sure that particularly for our
young people that we are getting them
the support they need in schools to to
Grapple with some of these things and
you know have fulfilling lives so you
actually that will come out I think
later this year but stand by on that as
well as the extra money that's going on
which you know we need to make sure gets
down to your you know to what you're
wrapping with on the ground we need to
make sure that we get the overall
approach and policy right in a way that
in the past wasn't done properly but now
that that within you the new act that
we're going to put forward will will be
fixed
right who's uh who's next yes uh man
education so I I run a very large
academic Academy trust but I'm not going
to ask about that this morning because I
think we're surrounded by Health people
so the two things that I want to ask you
is you've been to to Northeast hospital
and it is in desperate need of a rebuild
so I quite like to ask the question what
are your plans for for rebuilding some
of the hospitals that really are
desperate and lots of money is lost
because they're actually spending it on
repairs and maintenance whereas if they
had new bills that would make a
difference and the second question I
want to ask because it's the elephant in
the room when are you actually going to
pay nurses properly right so actually
great uh the great that we do both of
those together
um so on on the hospital maintenance
side so there's actually the NHS capital
budget at the moment is the largest it's
ever been and that goes into a mix of
different things it goes into there's
probably a few goes into r d which is
important um it goes into upgrades so
lots of hospitals that need upgrades are
currently in the process of being I
think almost 100 are being upgraded as
we speak and that could be smaller scale
interventions there's there's a very
large program of new builds and rebuilds
which is part of the faulty Hospital
program and we're putting in more kit
into all the hospitals right so
Community diagnostic Centers MRI
scanners those types of things building
elective surgical hubs all those things
actually going to help us get the
backlog down so with that big capital
budget that we've got those are the
different elements of it and we're
trying to get the balance right between
all those uh all those things but that
overall pie is the biggest that it's
ever been going into going into that
here now actually links to your second
question right and I'm glad you asked
about uh about it it's a bit odd if we
managed to get through the session
without uh talking about it right and
many of you here will be thinking about
it many of you here will be members of
your union and let me let me explain you
know where we are and what and what
we're doing right first of all I as
hopefully you can tell right the reason
I'm here I've got enormous gratitude for
all of you who are doing an incredible
job working very hard at the moment in
the NHS particularly this winter which
has been really challenging for the
reasons I talked about and that's come
on the back of two years which have been
really challenging because of covid
right so believe me I I I know and as I
was talking about I grew up in an NHS
family I understand how important
Healthcare is and the difference it
makes that's why we prioritized it last
year in spite of the difficult things
now then what does that mean for for pay
like I would love right nothing would
give me more pleasure than to wave a
magic wand and have everyone all of you
paid lots more right of course of course
who wouldn't want to be to do that of
course I want to be able to do that what
we did do is there's a independent
process that goes through this and
provides a recommendation to the
government so it wasn't actually wasn't
our decision an independent process
takes evidence from the unions from the
government from others and it says look
we think the appropriate pay level pay
increase is X they said roughly five
percent right so we said fine we'll
accept that that's what we've put in
place for last year
um so you know why not why not more
right is your question and and that's a
completely fair question and I guess I'd
say a couple of things you know we've
had gosh handful of different questions
about lots of different things right you
asked about Hospital upgrades right we
asked about Community Pharmacy we asked
about training for new nurses and what
support we can give them look people
with learning disabilities children with
learning disabilities
that gives you a sense of all the things
right that we have to try and balance
and that's my job that's not an easy job
right and that's what we have to do
fundamentally right I can tell you hand
on heart that there's more money going
into the NHS and social care than there
ever has been before I can tell you that
when we had to make some really
difficult decisions last year we went
out of our way to protect the NHS and
social care and give it even more and
that meant difficult things elsewhere
which I've got some criticism for right
so I can tell you that right so overall
the pie is as big as it's ever been and
in the circumstances was was prioritized
but then within that pie we've got to
figure out what's the right balance
between
pay and between all these other things
that we have to do and it's not an easy
thing to get right right and you know
you we'd like you as you said we want a
new and upgraded hospital we need more
MRI scanners we need more support for
new nurses Etc right so that's the
balance that we get right it's a
question about what's affordable within
in that pie and I don't want to put any
of your taxes up that's what it comes
down to right I doubt any of you would
thank me if I came here and said great
well I've put up all your taxes right I
don't want to do that because it's tough
enough at home as it is at the moment
for all of you with your bills and
everything else so you're figuring out
how to pay for these things is part of
my job and I think we've kind of we're
where we are with taxes at the moment we
can't put them up anymore right then we
need to be getting them down so that's
what constrains me on one end and then
the other thing is inflation
right what is the number one challenge
all of you have day to day at home it's
like every time you open a bill it's
like oh my gosh what is going on right
every single bill every single week and
it's been like that for a while right
the most important thing that I need to
do for all of you right not just
everyone working in the NHS not just our
nurses but everyone in the country the
most important thing is to harm
inflation
right the thing that's going to make the
biggest difference to all of your lives
and everyone else's life if by the end
of this year right bills are not going
up at the rate that they have been over
the past year because that is a thing
that is eating into all of your quality
of life all of your standard of living
that's the thing that says great I can't
go on holiday this year or I can't buy
these presents or I can't go out for
this meal I can't do any of these things
because everything is just going up and
up and up I've got to get a grip of that
for all of you it's the most important
thing and if we don't do that we won't
be able to afford anything in the future
because inflation is one of these things
this is a very young audience right so
you won't remember like when this goes
badly wrong as it did in the past in the
1970s and is that everyone here is too
young to remember that but you know when
this gets wrong and if we're still
talking about high inflation in a year's
time right it is going to be awful for
all of you right it will be we won't be
able to afford to invest anymore in
anything right and you no one will be
able to spend money on anything they
want because inflation would have just
been going up and up and up an important
part of us getting a grip of inflation
and halving it is making sure that the
government's responsible with its
borrowing because if that gets out of
control it makes it worse and it's about
making sure pay settlements are
reasonable and fair and that's so when
you have periods of high inflation what
happened in the past is everyone said
okay inflation was at 15 we should all
get paid 15 and then you have a kind of
vicious cycle which you never recover
from so you know it would be the wrong
thing to do of course it would make my
life easier to say yeah sure great let's
just go ahead it would be a bad thing
for all of you if that meant inflation
was running really high in a year's time
we hadn't got a grip of it and I don't
want to do that for you so even though
it makes my life a bit more difficult
today I really think it's the right
thing for all of you and everyone else
if we just get through this but look I I
hear you right I hear you I hear all of
you I've talked to your unions the
health secretary's talking to your
unions we want to find a way through
this I know things are tough and I know
what an incredible job you do so rest
assured that we are trying our hardest
to find a way through sorry for the long
answer but
hahaha
there we go right who's uh who's next uh
yes
Miss
hi my name's Anna I'm a Primary Care
Network pharmacist and do you have any
plans to tackle disease prevention for
example heart disease or diabetes which
will keep people out of hospital and in
turn ease of pressure on Emergency Care
yes I mean that is excellent well it's a
little bit what I was talking about
before about blood pressure checks and
is there more other testing that we can
do in advance that does which prevents
conditions now I I mean I was just
upstairs with one of your colleagues
who's sitting right next to you with
this extraordinary invention right I
mean look you guys are basically I I
don't know if I'm portraying any
commercial Secrets but
um but you know just basically what you
have done here what your team
collectively have created is a brand new
you know urine based test for something
that at the moment requires you know
over a thousand pounds of quite invasive
testing to be done in a hospital and you
say I said figure it out hang on we
don't need to do that we can do it with
a simple you know like a covert test
right and we can do it at home and it
costs literally a thousand times less
and that means that many more people can
go and get that test done and we can
figure out that they've got this
particular condition earlier and then we
can get them the medicine that they need
to stop it getting worse like that is an
amazing example of what is possible but
that's possible because of all of you
right that's we've got some amazing
researchers here who I'm really proud to
have just supported by the government
with a big Grant and I think one of the
other things that we do in that big NHS
capital budget is fund r d right which
doesn't sound very exciting but there's
that government r d money that's gone
into this particular building to support
that particular team who have developed
this new test which they've worked on
with all of you who are practitioners
and nurses to make sure that it would
actually work right that is now going to
save tons of people's lives and save us
money over time and prevent bad things
from happening right and so you guys
right here are a kind of amazing
microcosm of what is possible
um to do that and and that's why it's
working and you know really excited
about the team seeing that that thing
grow but it's just a small example
sample of what we need to do a lot more
of but it is absolutely part of the
answer absolutely there was another
gentleman somewhere over here I think
yes
thank you Tim Thompson and Dean of
health and Life Sciences at Tucson
University
um there was a report from a police
exchange a few weeks ago advocating for
an increasing medical places and medical
schools partly focused on the community
as we're talking about today and I just
wondered if any of that featured into
your thinking around the workforce
planning going forward yeah so that will
be absolutely a part of it and I think
the NHS has never had this long-term
Workforce plan and it needs to right so
we've got a plan for the future and
that's what that plan will do right so
we'll look at well here's the different
types of well it's how many people we
need is what they should all do and then
are we training them now because the
whole problem is if you decide today
yikes we need more anesthetists you know
what turns out can't magic up underneath
this overnight for example
um so I think that's why we need to have
a long-term approach and then part of
that is working backwards to what we're
doing in training schools so that's what
that plan exactly will do I think the
other thing though it's really important
is is about the different types of role
and I was going and I was talking to
some of you earlier right and you guys
are going to go out and and do these
amazing jobs and help us solve this
problem
um but it's it's making sure that we
have all the different types of people
doing all the different types of things
that that we need and it's you know in
primary care it's what can pharmacists
do that GPS are currently doing right
but also like even that what a pharmacy
technicians doing today or should be
doing that pharmacists could do for all
of you right there's the emergency
medical technicians the new types of
role what nurses are doing you know you
know because we're in the profession
right all the different types of nursing
qualification there are can we you know
nurses ordering blood tests x-rays
X-rays and a e departments which now is
possible which wasn't always possible
isn't happening by the way in every
hospital which which it could be so
those are all the things we need to look
at as well it's not just about the
number of people important though that
is it's about making sure all of you
because you're more than just a number
right we want to make sure that you a
have really fulfilling careers right
which so that you're enjoying what
you're doing and feel that you're
working on the stuff that you qualified
and trained to do and not lots of other
stuff but also we're figuring out how to
make you all really effective right and
and that's an important part of that
plan it's not just about numbers it's
about who's doing what are they doing it
as effectively as possible and doing it
in a way that's really fulfilling for
all of them so you guys are going to
help us build that plan because you're
the ones on the ground and actually
that's why when I'm around and you know
Amanda and I had lots of people to
Downing Street the other week you know
it's that really simple stuff people
saying hang on I work in this hospital
I'm allowed to order an X-ray I'm out
and order a blood test and I have to go
and talk to the consultant I can just
speed that process up and then I go and
work at this other hospital and I can't
and we're sitting there going well that
doesn't seem sensible does it right so
it's small things like that that you
guys tell us and that's how we help
improve it for you and and for everyone
else as well
yes where yes sir
thank you much my name is Johnny I'm a
local um cardiothoracic surgeon cancer
lead and run Target along health check
locally
we have something in common because I
was inspired by Kath Monaghan as well
I'm not quite as bright as Catherine not
being a surgeon but we have run a
parallel service where we have taken a
nurse into the community post lung
surgery for cancer and we visit them day
one day two and day three
postoperatively and of course discharge
and it's reduced our readmission rate
from 30 to 9 and reduced our inpatient
stay from 6.6 days to 4.9 days so my
question is can we have the hospital at
home and the virtual Awards apply to the
surgical Community not only to my more
clever medical colleagues yes well
um we're all members of cath fan club
here it seems um no so the the quick
answer the quick answer is yes and I I
don't know it's a you know you guys will
will know this because you're all
practitioners maybe not everyone in the
media will know this but like this
concept of virtual Awards is actually
just transformational and what what is
this what does it mean and that's right
I know there's some people up here so
I'll come up to you for a question in a
second as well sorry
um so you know what does it mean right
this is as you said that we can
basically set up hospitals at home for
people right and we can do it in areas
like COPD respiratory conditions we can
do it in areas like Frailty and the
technology allows us to do that together
with new ways of working that you know
that Kath has helped develop here and it
does exactly what you've said it means
that we can stop people coming into
Hospital in the first place it means we
can and it means we can get them home
quicker and actually we were going over
some of the stats this morning at North
T is how we're able to do it I think it
was in COPD we were discussing right 20
30 reduction in admissions for people
coming in because of this type of
service for COPD and a reduction in an
average day from five to three days I
mean this is huge right you replicate
that across the Tara NHS if we can roll
that out properly it'll make a big
difference so that's part of the plan
today so when you go home and have a
flick through this plan
um it will say that we've got currently
about 7 000 virtual Ward beds and that's
going to grow to at least 10 000 over
the course of the next year and on top
of that we want to make sure that the
utilization of those beds goes up from
where it is currently which is lower
than it should be and we're going to
support all those hospitals who don't
quite know how to do it properly because
what you're doing is pioneering right
and what we need to do is support every
other hospital to introduce virtual
Awards and think that way because it's a
new way of thinking and it requires as
Katha said it requires a bit about the
Box thinking sometimes but if we get
everyone to do that it's going to be
amazing and that is part of a big part
of our plan today
um so thank you for raising it I'm just
going to go upstairs right we've got any
questions up there I can't right yes sir
is that your hand raised hi
it's yours
um sorry
um just wanted to know if there are any
plans for dentist and orthodontist
backlogs
treatments plan are like 12 to 18 months
as per the email so any any thoughts on
that please thank you yeah so with with
regard to Dentistry so there's uh
there's we've got about I think 400 some
some 400 500 more dentists doing NHS
Dentistry at the moment than we did have
and we we went through and redid the
contract of which will improve the
provision of services and we're in the
process of talking more to see what
further changes we can make to the
contract to improve things and and
together with that more money went into
NHS Dentistry out of that big pot of
money that I talked about earlier and
the key thing there are more hundreds
more NHS dentists today than than there
were and the contract reforms are a part
of how we can continue to improve
performance any other questions from up
there I can't quite say is that is that
yes sir is that hand raised
thank you I'm a senior partner in a GP
practice in East Durham and uh we've
just come out of delivering a
significant amount of the covert
vaccination program and now dealing with
recovery there's been investment in
general practice over the last four
years of additional roles social
prescribing link workers pharmacists
paramedics to support GP practice
because the level of appointments demand
has risen significantly well my question
is is the bureaucracy or general
practice on targets demands on on on
performance is increasing as well is
there any way we could reduce the
bureaucracy and general practice so that
our Workforce could concentrate on
delivering care yes so one of the things
that we discussed in Downing Street a
couple of weeks ago in our recovery
Forum when we had our session on Primary
Care was exactly this and we had some of
your colleagues and representatives from
a Royal College there and they've given
they gave me a kind of bunch of very
practical things that they think we
could change so we're in the process of
looking through those and as part of our
primary care plan we'll see what we can
do but that's why these things are so
important you know people want to why am
I out it's it's that's very helpful
right because we you know I need to hear
from you what are the practical things
that you think you are doing that really
don't add very much value and detract
from looking after your patients and you
know they're all well-intentioned I'm
sure whenever some body introduced these
regulations or form filling it was done
with good reason so then we just need to
go and look and say actually does that
make sense anymore and we're happy to do
that and we'll be doing that as part of
the the primary care recovery plan right
I mean right any any yes yes let's get a
question here sorry Emmett right I'm
being waved at says
and I'm just going to go back to work
for our services lately yeah okay
and so obviously to staff all of these
um additional beds and additional
capacity both within the hospital
language
we do need we need staff
um one of the initiatives
um that we we look at at North tees
where I'm from is around our alternative
Workforce modeling and I know you've
touched on that slightly there around
who can do what when and when and how
appropriate is that I suppose my
question is how do we
um or what support can you give us I
suppose to actually widen that and
really widen people's expectations of
that because even
um from a
um a safe Staffing perspective some of
our national tools that we use and we're
governed to use which are great they're
very traditionally nursing tools we have
a safer nursing care tool that
recommends our staffing recommendations
but actually for me personally I'd like
to see
um tools that we can use that will
actually Encompass a much wider work for
us and a Workforce that is fit for the
future and it stores it's just around
yeah yeah is it support coming from
National guidance and things yeah so I
think you know what that's a really good
point and it uh it's something we need
to to do as part of this and again it's
something that we've we've been
discussing and I've been talking to the
chief medical officer to Chris witty and
Stephen Palace as a medical director I
forget these titles right Amanda
um and about making sure that we are
clear about what everyone can do and
that's part of the question before is
that you know it's actually are we
saying all the right things that allow
you on the ground to do things in a way
that actually makes sense for you and a
lot of people said to us they they feel
that often they can't do some of these
things because it kind of says that they
shouldn't and when clearly actually we
think you should and you can be trusted
to do it and that's a sensible and right
thing for all of you to be doing so in
the process we're currently looking at
all of the the guidance that comes from
on high and to make sure that it
supports you to do exactly as you
describe you know work effectively and
work flexibly and know that you've got
the full support and backing of your
clinical leads as you do that and it's
an important part of making a reaction
virtual Wars is another example of that
actually part of the reason some places
they say oh gosh is that okay that we
don't have them in the hospital that
they're at home they say oh we're a bit
worried about that Hospital's safe you
know just put everyone in the hospital
they need to have the confidence to know
no hang on actually come and see what's
happening in Northeast you know talk to
the clinic clinical leads who are doing
it it is safe in fact it's not it is you
know safe and better right and the
guidance should reflect that and they
need to have the examples that you know
they they see places like this getting
it done really well um so that's part of
you know when I say we have we've got
this great plan our job is to go deliver
it now and part of delivering it is
making sure that no one anywhere in the
country can say oh I can't do the
virtual Ward for example or because I'm
not really allowed to right or it's not
safe so that's exactly what we'll do to
make sure we deliver it right okay go on
last one yes and I'll take some
questions from the media quickly as well
thank you I'm Anna barnardo
reconstructive plastic surgeon at South
tees and I'm really proud of our
surgical Services we've really
collaborated well both before covert
enduring to bring our waiting list down
in an equitable way for all of our
patients across all the Specialties and
one of the ways we achieved that was
rather than just looking at the numbers
of patients on the waiting list we
looked at the actual hours of operating
on the waiting list as a better and more
accurate measure of how we should
distribute our resource so point one was
whether that was something that we could
perhaps roll out for resource allocation
generally in the surgical services and
then the second point was there have
been a number of excellent points about
increasing the workforce and ways that
we can bring more resource in but what
measures are we going to put in place
both urgently and in the medium and
longer term to retain the expertise at
middle and late career stage across
nursing management surgery medicine
anesthetics because we're just
hemorrhaging expertise and Workforce
really yeah no thank you so on on your
second question that part of that across
the board as I was talking about making
sure that your jobs are fulfilling and
that people feel that they actually are
enjoying what they're doing and they're
recognized for the incredible job they
do and obviously pay is a part of that
that you know look at some of the
paramedics and I talk to ambulance Crews
and I talk to them about what's on their
mind you know it's not just pay right if
of course it's not and you know that
you're all nodding right it's about this
the intensity with which they're having
to work the feeling that they can't do
what they want to do well for their
patients because they're stuck sitting
at Handover delays so actually if we get
this discharge thing right and we can
release the you know capacity in the
hospital that will help the a e
Department that's got nothing to do with
the ambulance and the paramedics but
they their job will become better and
more fulfilling and they'll feel better
about it because we did those things
over there right so there's nothing to
do with their pay but if we actually can
reduce hospital bed occupancy down flow
improves we do some of these other
things in a e and suddenly they're just
able to show up do what they want to do
and get back out to helping people all
and they're not having all of those
delays they'll feel much better about
their day-to-day lives and their
day-to-day jobs right so I think
actually part of this will help with
that
um and your other question was if remind
me was uh
Yes actually that's yes so really
interesting so yes there is um so part
of our elective recovery plan is exactly
that and you guys have done a great job
and I know because you're part of my
trust
um we're all over the ferrariage and we
did do a really good job uh actually and
we had separate hot and cold sites
during covid and we kept going with lots
of stuff particularly on cancer which is
so thank you to you and your colleagues
for doing that because the results were
really impressive and it's made a
difference to my constituents as well so
you know part of it actually is having
more data and Technology around
management of your backlog in its
entirety is clearly an Obviously good
thing to do and again it's not what I
was saying before it sounds kind of
obvious okay we should use some
technology to help us analyze our
waiting list and then organize ourselves
uh in the most optimal way that doesn't
actually happen everywhere right I mean
and that's part of our job is to spread
that best practice there's a couple of
different systems you know Foundry is
another one there are a few different
systems that do a really good job of
exactly what you're saying Chelsea and
Westminster is another truss which used
some I.T which made a 28 almost a third
reduction in their backlog just by
organizing for them it was cleaning
through their list then organizing their
theater and all of you the nurses who
have to work in theaters know there's
like optimizing your theater list on a
day-to-day basis where I can see what
you're not doing right you know the
managing the cancellations you're like
that is so important and again the
technology can really help us do that
and your point on the metrics I will
take away with Amanda
and you did it great even better
brilliant
yeah no great no that is great because
then that doesn't have to go through
some complicated procurement process
which will take too long so Excel will
solve the problem for us no it's great
but it's a really it's a straightforward
thing right and again a lot of what I'm
talking about I actually probably sounds
relatively you know it sounds exactly
boring and a bit operational but you
know that's what it takes right I mean
it you know like we need to make sure
that we support all of you so that you
can be you know you know as amazing as
you want to be in serving your patients
and getting the Excel right about who's
doing what when is just an important
part of that so um no it's great so
thank you for raising it that's very
good news right okay we've got some
media questions go on Beth kick us off
prime minister I've got two questions if
I may well I just try to try and keep
them quick because
let me crack on average ambulance wait
times for heart attacks and straights in
December you'll know when 19 minutes the
NHS standard is 18 minutes to give
people the best chance to survive it's
not about convenience it's about whether
people live or die but today you're not
even recommitting to get back to that
Target at all my point to you is people
watching this will think that that is
not good enough and do you accept it's
going to take years to fix the NHS and
if I may a question on the deems ahawi
uh this week will mark 100 days of your
Premiership here you are talking about
the NHS but your tenure in number 10 has
been more characterized about sleaze
than sound government are you frustrated
or Furious even about Nadeem zahawi's
conduct and the Damage it's done to you
personally and your government thank you
so look on on the second one right I you
know what I've done is follow a process
which is the right process Integrity is
really important to me all of you guys
want to see that governments run
properly that it's wrong with integrity
and as accountability when people don't
behave in a way that they should or
something doesn't go right and that's
what we've done so we have an
independent advisor that's what the
government has it's not you know it's
not it's not me who's doing it and what
I ask when all these questions started
coming to light about uh Nadim zahawi
you know I asked the independent advisor
to get to the bottom of it
to provide me with the facts and then on
the basis of the facts which he did
relatively quickly over the part of last
week I was able to make a very quick
decision that it was no longer
appropriate for nadines are we to
continue in government and that's why
he's no longer there that's what I've
done it relates to things that happened
well before I was prime minister so
unfortunately I can't change what
happened in the past what you can hold
me accountable for is that what did you
do about it you know what I did as soon
as I knew about the situation was
appoint somebody independent looked at
it got the advice and then acted pretty
decisively
um to move on because that's what I
think all of you deserve from me and
from from government and you know what I
am focused on is the other part of your
question on ambulance waiting times that
is what I am doing and of course it's
not good enough of course gosh what
happened in December was not was not
great no right it was not great for any
of you working in the NHS it was not
great for patients you know what I'd say
is there were a range of reasons why it
was bad right I mean man will have the
statistics should we have from November
to December we're a seven times increase
in the number of people who ended up in
hospital with flu right it was probably
the worst season for flu in a decade in
the NHS it was so tough for all of you
and many other people and it was
something that Chris Whittier I've been
the pandemic he kind of flagged would
happen and rightly because you know when
you know when you've had a couple of
years of everyone either in lockdown or
being very very careful the natural
immunity that a population builds up to
flu just goes down and he was always
clear it was always a case that I could
see all of you naught in because you're
all Healthcare experts right it's always
going to be the case as soon as that
happened it was likely that flu would be
quite tricky right and that is what
happened and as I said we're not alone
it's the same in Scotland and Wales in
lots of other countries around the world
in terms of the plans today uh what you
know what they say is that we will get
back to 30 minutes over the course of
this year and then we will get back to
pre-pandemic levels thereafter now is
you know I would say that is ambitious
the reason being that the the scale of
improvement from where we are you have
to start from starting from where we are
the scale of improvement that I talked
about my opening remarks will represent
the largest and fastest Improvement in
NHS waiting time to Emergency Care on
record right if we can pull this off
that's what we're going to do we're
going to do it all together because you
guys are going to help us do it
um so I think it is ambitious and I also
think it's been rightly welcomed by lots
of people you know lots of your
colleagues helped us come up with a plan
that we put in place today and it's
really important for me when it just
come from government we have to talk to
all of you and your colleagues to get it
right and I'm really pleased actually
today lots of people from the profession
have said it's the right plan it will
make I think their words a significant
difference it's undoubtedly the right
things to focus on so look I you know
we've got the plan in place we've got
the money in place we just need to work
with all of you to deliver it now and
I'm confident it will it will make a
difference
um Robert Beth have you had to kind of I
really need to try and get around a few
others
I said
no what we've said is we will work
towards pre-pandemic levels after next
year but in the short and Here and Now
what we need to get to is is 30 minutes
over this year that's the plan I think
you will also see I mean look it's too
early to tell because the numbers will
come out in a month the things that
we're already doing I think you'll see
made a difference in January right I
think you will see a difference in the
January numbers compared to December
because some of the things we did on
discharge to move people out of
hospitals have already started have a
bit of an impact I think hopefully
fingers crossed but the numbers come out
for January you'll see that things are
already starting to improve Robert prime
minister good to see you
um Johnson Hancock bravaman zahawi I
probably missed a few why are so many
people at the top of your party finding
it so difficult to follow the rules
um and secondly if I may on the NHS
crisis
um
haven't you put the cart before the
horse we are seeing demoralized nurses
demoralized ambulance workers paramedics
doctors at least part of what you've got
to do to restore their morale is sort
this pay issue so when and how are you
going to do that
so on the first question I mean I've
talked about that before and look on on
the second question it it's actually
what we talked about you know with the
latest question at the beginning right
and you've heard the kind of long answer
that I gave on that
um and that's what we're doing right at
the beginning of this year the
government also reinvited all union
leaders you know whether it's the RCN
for some of you or all the others to
come in talk to their secretaries of
state to have those dialogues like of
course like we won't need to talk to
people to try and find a way through
this that's what's happening rest
assured that that's uh what's happening
it's not easy for all the reasons that I
outlined those are the things that we're
juggling with and we're going to work
through but look I'm confident that we
can find a way through and but we will
keep talking and we're already starting
to talk now about pay for this year
that's already happening and as I said
like we will keep at it until we can
find a resolution and all this and in
the meantime we're getting on we're
doing all these other things that we've
spent a really good amount of time today
talking about which I think are going to
support you and support the NHS and make
a difference to people so we can do
we'll do both those things at the same
time
right Natasha
I said look as I've addressed before
Robert like the things that happened
before I was prime minister I can't do
anything about what I think you can hold
me to account for is how I deal with the
things that arise on my watch and as
you've seen you know when it came to
Nadine's day are we I asked independent
advisor to look at it straight away
acted on his findings straight away it
actually gave you some confidence that
these things mattered to me and that I
will take whatever steps are necessary
to restore the Integrity back into
politics and you can have confidence
that the process works
Natasha
thank you prime minister
um you said on the steps of Downing
Street and you've also just mentioned it
now Integrity it's a word that really
matters to you you've lost two cabinet
ministers now you might lose a third
your Deputy
um is that word still important to you
is that word still integral to your
government
um and secondly we had some very
worrying reports last night into
Britain's defense
um we've obviously seen the effects of
Russia Today coming from some of the
front pages as well if the integrated
review does call for more defense
spending for our armed forces would you
like to promise today to give it to them
thank you so when it comes to the armed
forces and defense something that we
should all be really proud of is what
our country has done to support Ukraine
and stand up to Russian aggression and
you know that that's something that
we've led the world in and we will
continue to do so so one of the
announcements I made just a couple of
weeks ago was that we as a country would
provide heavy tanks to Ukraine and you
may see that they call Challenger 2
tanks and again we're were the first
major country to say that and what
that's led to through the conversations
that I've been having with our partners
around the world is other countries like
Germany like America and others also
saying that they will do the same thing
so again we've slightly you know we've
we've LED everyone that's really
important because it will provide the
support that Ukraine needs to hopefully
progress against Russia over the early
part of this year and it's a it's a
really key ask from president zielinski
to all of us to give that support to him
so I'm really pleased that we're able to
do that that's what we're doing and also
I think look that is all part of keeping
you safe right fundamentally yes this is
happening in one sense far away but our
security is slightly indivisible right
you know Russian aggression impacts us
as we saw in our own country you know
not that many years ago and standing up
to aggression everywhere is good for all
of our security and that's why what
we're doing is actually ultimately in
all of our interests and we will
continue to do it and you know I'm
confident that we can make progress and
this year and when I was Chancellor we
increased funding in the armed forces by
a record amount as well because we
wanted we recognized that the world had
changed and was becoming a less safe
place and that needed extra resourcing
so that's gone in and again we need to
make sure that goes on all the right
things but that's what we do
great and I think we have we have one
question from the northern Echo is that
right is it who's here someone hey it's
Bill from them this better be the last
one right okay fine we've massively gone
over sorry Friday and you guys were
having two questions each that doesn't
help right gone Friday saw yet another
tragic death of a teenager due to ninth
crime in the Northeast and we've seen
the impact that's had on the health
services in the Northeast what message
do you have to The Grieving families who
are asking for answers and wanting more
protection yeah I my my heart goes out
to them and that's tragic I have two
young kids and I can't imagine right you
know one of my kids or any young person
losing their life in that way it's awful
um what what can we do to stop that
happening in the future It's a
combination of things it's about putting
more police officers on the street and
that's part of our commitment to putting
20 000 more police officers across the
country and I haven't got the numbers in
front of me for Cleveland police but
there will be more police officers on
the streets
um in the Northeast as a result of that
investment we're already three quarters
of the way through so that will help but
it's also about giving the police the
powers they need so when it comes to
knife Crime Stop and search it's quite
an important tool that the police have
is that in order to prevent knife crime
from happening and we as a government
change the rules around that to make it
easier for the police to use stop and
search that will make a difference going
forward and then the last thing that's
really important to me as um I have two
young girls and I think in particular we
need to do a better job of tackling
violence against women and girls right
for far too long you know too many women
too many girls have not felt as safe as
they need to be deserve to be should be
and we've got to do a better job of that
that's now the police officers will help
stop and search will help other things
will help we're putting investments into
communities around the Northeast and
just improving things like Street
lighting CCTV making it feel safer when
many of you walk around in the evening
and because that's really important
we've you know we've changed all the the
way that we approach rape sexual
violence and domestic abuse all these
things that we didn't tackle properly in
the past and we're in the process of
improving and that's really important
and you should absolutely hold me to
account for that I want all of you to be
able to walk around and feel safe and
when things don't go right that you know
Justice happens and it happens quickly
and I think we are making progress and
things are moving in the right direction
but the tragedy that you
talked about shows us that we've got
work to do and we'll keep at it until we
get it done brilliant all right thank
you very much for your time it's been a
great pleasure
all right